pas bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en
direct pour cette édition spéciale
venez sa bière chez faire j'imagine que
vous avez suivi aussi depuis la france
les chaînes américaines quel a été votre
vie votre réaction par rapport au
traitement de la campagne présidentielle
écoutez j'ai trouvé comme d'habitude
qu'il y avait une partie des médias qui
était très en titre up
quitte à le caricaturer à le vilipender
et en même temps train pas raison ça
augmente l'audience et le lectorat de
ces mêmes médias donc c'est un jeu assez
classique on a vu pendant à peu près
tout le mandat le premier mandat de
trump c'est un jeu que vous dites on a
vu pendant le premier mandat de train
mais c'est vrai que les médias sont
extrêmement partisan à moi en tant que
français c'est vrai que j'ai regardé ses
chaînes américaines j'ai été extrêmement
surprise il y avait de véritables édito
pas vraiment voilà un travail de
journaliste objectif je crois que
personne ne me contredira
excepté fox news qui était très propre
rump cnl est très pro by dane ça ne pose
pas plus de problèmes que ça ici aux
etats unis
alors en fait je suis très content que
vous disiez vous même puisque je suis
assez prudente pour engager un pronostic
ou un qualificatif sur les médias mais
effectivement certains médias meanstream
américains comme cnn
oui non oui c'est à dire que vous savez
c'est toujours les gens qui critiquent
n'aime pas être critiqué eux ils peuvent
se permettre de dire des choses
affreuses sur trump de le caricaturer
mais ils n'acceptent pas forcément qu'on
les critique eux mêmes pour leurs excès
je crois qu'il ya tout un pan du show
business et des médias aux états unis
qui sont allés tellement loin qui n'ont
même plus le recul et la coupe lalla ne
réalise même pas à quel point ils sont
ridicules dans leur caricature de trump
aider surtout des électeurs de train
parce qu'en définitive on peut ne pas
aimer trump on peut lui trouver de
grands défauts mais il ne faut jamais
insulter l'électorat au niveau parce
qu'au final il faut bien que le peuple
ait
vous ne pouvez pas gérer un état si vous
passez votre temps à critiquer les
l'électorat qui est quand même la
majorité présente
vanessa bien chez fin dans le même temps
quand on regarde ces médias on sent une
forme de de bonne foi une forme voilà de
sincérité à dire aux électeurs trump est
un homme dangereux il ne faut pas voter
pour lui
c'est le discours qui est véhiculé en
tout cas par la plupart des
éditorialistes sur cnn est ce que vous
c'est quelque chose qui qui vous choque
où vous vous l'expliquez comment écouter
je le vois aussi d'une presse qui n'est
pas forcément américaine je pense qu'il
ya deux phénomènes qui se passe il y
avait sur et à mesure des années quand
les gens sont pris dans une certaine
idéologie et qu'il est que pendant des
années il rabâche le même discours je
pense que c'est extrêmement difficile
sur le plan neurologique et
psychologique de prendre d'avoir un peu
plus de flexibilité de recul
donc je les exonère si vous voulez de
persévérer dans leur idéologie propres
dans l'âme et apolitique qui est la leur
un deuxième phénomène ya le phénomène de
groupe vous avez tendance à répéter ce
que disent les autres plutôt que de
conserver une voix indépendante
il ya un journaliste quand suis
énormément aux états unis enfin tout cas
pour les supporters de 30 qui est sur
fox et théo kirk hartson qui lui
correspond justement à cette liberté de
ton et d'esprit critique
mais pour le reste il ya un espèce de
mimétisme collectif que vous ajoutez une
idéologie propres qu'il a depuis
plusieurs années c'est très difficile de
changer
que ce soit pour un démocrate ou pour un
républicain pour supporter de n'importe
quel candidat mais là le monde
médiatique est allé tellement loin qu'en
définitive on a l'impression que c'est
comme des voleurs qui sont pris en
course poursuite
ils ont tellement peur d'être rattrapé
par la patrouille ils font ce qu'ils
font sur la d'accélération et
puis un jour ils vont se prendre le mur
dans le même temps vanessa bien je sais
faire c'est vrai que on l'a vu ici en
parlant avec des américains il est très
compliqué aujourd'hui d'avouer entre
guillemets pour un électeur qui le
votent pour donald trump tout de même
est ce que vous vous interrogez vous en
tant que républicaine sur voilà cette
espèce de tabou aujourd'hui
trump a stigmatisé voilà quelque chose
de répulsifs vous vous le prenez comme
ça il vous vous l'expliquez comment
parce qu'il faut peut-être aussi
s'interroger sur ce point je pense qu'il
ya eu un tel 30 bashing une telle
violence à l'égard de l'électorat de 30
effectivement certaines personnes
peuvent avoir peur ne veulent pas être
stigmatisés socialement ne veut pas être
pointés du doigt bon moi j'ai la chance
d'avoir la double culture
donc mes amis français français quand
ils savent que je soutiens trempé que je
vote pour lui s'étonne après il ya ceux
qui vont peut-être à m'agresser au
premier abord et auquel j'explique
pourquoi je votre trempe et qu'elle
j'explique la situation aux états unis
puis la situation que je considère être
plus global donc je pense que c'est par
la pédagogie d'explication maintenant
tout le monde n'a pas forcément le temps
ou ne sait pas forcément comment faire
pour expliquer ça
position donc pour éviter le conflit la
plupart des gens effectivement dans ce
cas là préfèrent s'abstenir de déclarer
qu'il soutienne un candidat que 60,30
points d'autres c'est toujours la peur
d'être stigmatisés stigmatiser être
isolés du groupe vanessa bien chez faire
vous restez avec nous il ya jean claude
debons jouant vice président du cercle
de réflexion
france-amérique qui nous rejoint en
duplex depuis paris merci jean claude un
bon jour on évoquait donc avec vanessa
billard gfr ce traitement jugé en tout
cas par les républicains peu objectif
alors il est vrai voilà comme je le
disais en préambule que quand on regarde
les chaînes américaines
elle ne s'en cache pas vraiment il ya
cnn les autres et puis fox news d'un
côté qui programme mais le reste est
assez pro démocrates vous vous expliquer
cela comment il ya une forme de la 2d de
nos complexes aux états unis de la part
des journalistes a finalement affiché
leur opinion alors le phénomène auquel
on assiste aux états unis qui ont
renforcé aux états unis mais qu'on
assiste qu'on retrouve aussi ailleurs
c'est que la presse tout d'abord est de
plus en plus engagée engagés derrière
des personnalités fortes ou à un certain
nombre de tendances et donc on le
retrouve très facilement aux états unis
mais j'ajouterais aussi une chose c'est
que la presse américaine est aujourd'hui
probablement à l'image de la société
américaine extrêmement cuvée extrêmement
brillante et politiquement chacun
campant sur ses positions chacun ayant
des positions prédéterminé savez il ya
un professeur américain de la brookings
institution qui a écrit récemment un
ouvrage dits valides family validant
politique où il montre bien ce clivage
cette opposition finalement il décore ne
se parlent plus chaque chaque camp ainsi
l'hypothèse fait sa politique et on
assiste exactement la même chose côté
coûté presse américaine j'ajoute
probablement que la personnalité du
président trump a un peu renforcé le
maury n'est pas à l'origine mais il a
probablement renforcés vanessa bien chez
faire justement par rapport à ce qu'on
vient de dire est ce que vous craignez
que cela pèse justement sur les
électeurs et donc sur le résultat les
médias ont ré fait leur travail
justement en défaveur de donald trump
vous le craignez en tout cas non parce
que je pense que l'excès des médias
jouent en faveur de train et nous
l'avons vu notamment dans toute cette
période de confinement ils ont tellement
voulu être dans la dans cette idéologie
quelques qui le soutiennent depuis tant
d'années et je crois que ça fait le
succès de tram c'est de parler
directement à son électorat de parler
directement au peuple américain via les
réseaux sociaux ce qui a fait son succès
en 2016 et qui refera son succès à
l'heure actuelle il ya aussi d'autres
réseaux et par exemple un exemple que je
vais donner qui m'a frappé c'est en
dernier c'est la lettre de l'archevêque
vigano qui a été relayée par le général
flynn conseillait de train qui
effectivement est une lettre ouverte aux
catholiques qui on sait que l'électorat
catholique notamment dans certains et ça
est très important il ya une espèce de
réseaux d'information et de
communication qui bâille part c'est à
dire qu'il équipe laisse de côté les
médias classiques ou presque je vais pas
dire qu'on en a plus besoin parce qu'on
a on a toujours besoin de gens qui nous
expliquent qu'ils vont chercher
l'information qui met en forme mais là
il ya un tel raz le bol de la propagande
puisqu'en définitive la question
fondamentale une finesse et de vendée
qui finance ces médias
et à qui profite le crime c'est-à-dire
que quand on ne peut plus avoir un débat
où les deux partis sont représentés de
manière égalitaire où il ya vraiment un
échange d'arguments et de mise en
perspective et bien à ce moment là le
média n'est plus n'est plus un médiateur
n'a plus d'utilité donc plage tu pense
que nous sommes arrivés à bout enfin du
système et qui effectivement avantage de
il a très bien compris puisque c'est un
maître de la communication il parle
directement à son électorat il parle
directement au peuple américain et cela
se retranscrit dans les meetings on a
on a des fils des files de voitures qui
viennent au miti on n'a jamais vu autant
de gens qui viennent dans des meetings
politiques en plus dans une période de
covidien opte donc ça ça doit refléter
et ça doit mettre en
je pense que d'une certaine partie du
diable des médias et je vous mettrais
pas tout le monde dans le même dans la
même dans le même sac
une partie doit se remettre profondément
en question
oui mais si je puis intervenir
je sue oui oui jma moi je pense que
qu'effectivement ça ça se traduit coly
faye il peut y avoir des aspirations
d'un côté comme de l'autre parce que moi
j'entends nous nous sommes apolitiques
et on entendit les les deux sons de
cloche chez les 2 et 2 aussi bien
démocrates que les républicains qui
reproche à notre parti a même chose moi
je pense qu un mouvement de fond qui est
bien plus important où on a
effectivement des médias qui sont
relativement engagé et dans le cas
présent et notamment sur cnn j'entends
parfaitement des gens y compris des gens
démocrate qui me disent bombe à cnn cite
réorienter d'ailleurs un certain nombre
de journalistes ne s'en cache pas cnn
ils disent je suis j'espère que ce
président sera battu de la même façon
que chez fox news fox news on entend
aussi des journalistes ouvertement dié
qu'ils sont contre ou telle personnalité
démocrate d'ailleurs un certain nombre
de collaborateurs de la maison blanche
ont quitté la maison blanche ont reçu
ont rejoint foxnews houle inverse donc
on voit bien que ce phénomène qui n'est
pas je dis bien qui n'est pas exclusif à
donald trump
il te phénomène beaucoup plus profond et
je partage le fait qu' il est peut-être
souhaitable que les médias on trouve
dans un certain nombre de circonstances
retrouve le côté javier plus
scientifique plus rigoureux plus tôt
militants mais ça c'est une tendance
une tendance que l'on retrouve qu'au que
l'on doit aux états unis mais que l'on
retrouve également d'europe y compris en
france
vanessa bien chez faire effectivement la
liste de jean-claude beaujour est la
suivante c'est vrai que c'est une
tendance
médias engagés il n'empêche à votre goût
est ce qu'on en aa pris justement assez
sur le fond parce qu'on a beaucoup été
dans les attaques d'un veau camp comme
de l'autre mais on en apprenant
finalement peu sur le fond des
programmes
je pense que des programmes ont été
quand même éclipsé par la sphère co-lead
là il ya eu un événement majeur qui a
fait que je pense que le point de
cristallisation de toute la campagne a
été pour les américains en tout cas pas
du côté train de recouvrir sa liberté
son état et sa vie normale je crois que
c'est assez le thème principal
là il ya un clivage manifeste pour moi
sur le fond le fonds dont il ya plein de
sujets qui n'ont pas été abordés par
exemple si je prends le le couple biden
kamala harris je n'ai vu dans aucun
pratiquement médias ou très peu sauf des
médias alternatifs ou très spécialisés
sur la finance le fait que madame kamala
harris et la candidat dégâts femmes qui
veulent nous imposer quand même un
nouveau système économique c'est
d'ailleurs une raisons pour lesquelles
on ferme les commerces et les
indépendances ça profite à qui profite
le crime à une certaine industrie
américaine tard l'internât je dirais
plus donc les petits sujets de fond
n'ont pas été encore abordé à mon avis
parce que le sujet 30 centrale a tourné
autour du coc vide autour de la manière
dont on peut sortir de cette situation
et trump a été le seul je crois en tout
cas de mon point de vue qui a donné un
espace de liberté un espoir ne soyons
pas défaitistes
nous n'allons pas tous mourir il ya des
sites des solutions et allons en avant
ce qu'est l'esprit américain
on va pas non excusez moi on va pas
s'arrêter de vivre parce qu'il ya du
danger la vie c'est un danger permanent
alors je suis je suis d'accord qu'on n'a
pas plié
oui oui on n'en a pas pris beaucoup reçu
alliés sur les sites des deux candidats
je me dit je suis resté sur ma faim pour
les pour les deux candidats
donc là je vous rejoins aussi bien chez
démocrates mais aussi chez les
républicains il ne suffit pas d dire on
doit pas s'arrêter de vivre
c'est vrai que la gestion de la crise
sanitaire elle a été un petit peu
escabeau t on nous a pas dit
correspondance or les états unis ne s'en
sort toujours pas on parle de crise
sanitaire de milliers de chômeurs de
l'autre côté je conçois que de l'autre
côté
monsieur buydens ati qu'il fallait que
l'amérique retour son leadership
il ne nous a pas dit comment donc de ce
point de vue on reste aussi sur notre
faim moi je pense que c'est aussi le
problème de beaucoup de campagnes
électorales où on se contente parfois de
d'attac
parce que de mon point de vue il ya des
problèmes profonds aux états unis qui
aurait nécessité une réflexion beaucoup
plus approfondie et aucun des deux
candidats ne les ont abordés
je pense notamment en matière de
politique publique et il le fait que
l'amérique aujourd'hui est fracturée
entre ceux qui gagnent
d'une manière générale et puis les
disciples en compte s'il ya un peu
matière mende qu'aux états unis tessa ce
sujet là n'est pas véritablement abordé
l'un des deux candidats
tavannes et sabine hfr ont parlé de ces
fameux swing fait au combien important
on en a vu certains notamment la
pennsylvanie qui ont fait des victoires
notamment la dernière de votre poulain
donald trump dans quel état qu'elle est
appelée tôt vous allez suivre le plus
vous en tant que républicaine ce soir
quel état vous inquiète le plus alors je
ne sais pas si c'est l'état qui
m'inquiète qui inquiète le plus lés
c'est celui dont on a plus parlé et dont
j'ai un petit peu parlé tout à l'heure
en parlant napan silvani et avec
l'électorat une partie de l'électorat
catholique
d'abord je voudrais vous remercier votre
invité éric lien son analyse du vote en
floride est extrêmement précise et très
intéressante
effectivement j'ai le même chiffre que
lui sur l'électorat républicain en
floride est assez compliqué à comprendre
pour quelqu'un qui voit ça de
l'extérieur donc très franchement la
floride pas du tout inquiète la
pennsylvanie va être très intéressante
parce que ça se joue enfin ça se joue à
quelques voix par contre j'ai l'écho que
l'équipe
alors ça c'est les réseaux sociaux on
verra ce que ça donne mais que l'équipe
ben laden a déjà laissé tomber à
certains est à charnières en sachant que
ce n'était plus gagnable donc je pense
que nous allons très rapidement avoir un
résultat favorable pour 30
jean-claude bonjour effectivement la
pennsylvanie qui revient toujours et
encore la pennsylvanie de compte vendre
aux électeurs et surtout qui
traditionnellement prédit le futur
président américain s'est vraiment 7
hectares ce soir qu'il faut suivre en
premier lieu selon vous alors oui en
tout état de cause en termes de 2,2 de
synergies purement électorales de
tactique purement électorales comme la
vie dit auparavant il y a un certain
nombre il ya 270 grands électeurs à
obtenir pour que le candidat celui des
candidats en lice qui emporte les 270
est élu président des états unis
donc pour que nos auditeurs comprennent
nos téléspectateurs comprennent bien il
y à des états qui sont vraiment
démocrate vraiment républicain donc le
jeu est fait et ça se produit aussi
ailleurs et il ya des étapes dont on
sait qu'ils peuvent basculer d'un côté
comme de l'autre et c'est la raison pour
laquelle dix candidats ont fait beaucoup
campagne autour de 7 autour de ces
danser et à la pennsylvanie pourquoi ces
29 grands électeurs là où vous avez des
états qui vous apporte deux ou trois
grands électeurs donc pour le terme
mathématiques
l'enjeu moines donc c'est vraiment cela
c'est patent j'ai envie de dire la
géographie ou
l'affection qu'on peut avoir sur tel ou
tel état c'est vraiment jeux
mathématiques c'est de dire quand on est
candidat à une élection on va chercher
les voix en fonction du du modèle
électoral de de la règle électorale on
va chercher les voix là où elles sont et
les voies à prendre quel que soit le
candidat sont aujourd'hui
essentiellement sur les états où il ya
énormément de grands secteurs
on a vu la flore y pour 29 dans ce
secteur c'est le cas de la la
pennsylvanie c'est aussi le cas
l'arizona il ya beaucoup moins de grands
acteurs mais aussi du lys comme s'il ya
moins de grands secteurs mais en tout
cas on va chercher des voix le candidat
celui qui veut l'emporter va là où il ya
des voix et c'est là où il ya des voies
à prendre donc attendons attendons
effectivement c'est c'est tout ce qui
nous reste à faire plus que quelques
heures de patience jean-claude beaujour
ou plus peut-être vanessa bien rocher
faire est-ce que ce qui a le plus à
craindre ce soir ce n'est pas justement
de s'empêtrer voilà dans une élection
dont on ne connaîtrait pas l'issue au
petit matin
cette crise est la réponse est oui c'est
vrai c'est très possible parce
qu'effectivement on a vu qu'on a un
nombre record de votes par
correspondance et il faut garder à
l'esprit que chaque it à1 sa règle de
décompte des votes par correspondance
donc si je dis bien si le nombre de
bulletins dépouillés
et ça c'est indépendant c'est vraiment
une question de technique électorale si
le nombre de bulletins encore à
dépouiller est trop important pour
pouvoir annoncer ses résultats
il est évident que nous aurions à nous
aurions à attendre en revanche si le
nombre de bulletins à dépouiller était
marginal était marginal et bien est
possible que l'état que les états
concernés puissent annoncer le résultat
en disant qu'il finaliserait il
peaufinera dans des heurts à venir
vanessa bien je sais faire sur cette
question on connaîtra selon vous le nom
du futur président américain
oui je crois que les électeurs se
soutiennent du boom économique qui a été
réalisé sous trump et même juste après
la sortie du confinement que ce qu'on a
on a rattrapé en un trimestre
mettez 7% de croissance déjà les deux
tiers rattraper moi je suis en je
regarde les images des meetings je vois
les files d'attentes je vois des
supporteurs de tous les et tous les
horizons
je vois le chiffre de participation aux
fins de vote anticipé dans la communauté
afro américaine
chez les amish donc je d oka d'autres
que nous allons avoir une vague protruck
et qui sera brillamment réélue au matin
enfin pour nous ce qui est de manhattan
du 4 novembre
merci vanessa bien chez faire merci
également à jean claude debons jours en
tout cas on verra cela dans quelques
heures si vous avez raison à vanessa
billard merci à tous les deux de nous
avoir accompagnés